مشاهدينا نستكمل هذه التغطيه باخر الاخبار
حيث تتواصل حصيله ضحايا الزلزال الذي ضرب
تركيا وسوريا بالارتفاع فبحسب اخر الارقام
المعلنه خلف زلزال
1970 قتيلا في سوريا حتى الان بينما تتعثر
عمليه الاغاثه لنقص المعدات اما في تركيا
فقد خلف الزلزال
4544 قتيلا واكثر من 25 الف مصاب فضلا عن
تدمير اكثر من 5000 مبنى الرايس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان قال ان الزلزاله يعد من
اكبر الكوارث الطبيعيه في تاريخ البلاد
واعلنا حاله الطوارئ في المناطق المتضرره
تمتد لثلاثه اشهر
[موسيقى]
هذا الزلزال يعد من اكبر الكوارث الطبيعيه
في التاريخ ومختلف القوى الامنيه
والعسكريه تشارك في عمليات الانقاذ لكن
الدمار في المناطق المتضرره يتسبب في
اعاقه هذه العمليات خصصنا اكثر من خمسه
مليارات دولار لعمليات الانقاذ وندعو كل
الدول لمساعدتنا بالمعدات اللازمه بغض
النظر عن الوضع السياسي وهناك 70 دوله
عرضت المساعده في البحث والانقاذ كذلك
هناك طائرات مسيره تشارك في عمليات
الانقاذ وتم انشاء اربعه وخمسين الف موقع
للايواء في مناطق الزلزال وهناك خطه لفتح
فنادق انطاليا امام المتضررين ونعلن حاله
الطوارئ في المناطق المتضرره التي ستستمر
لمده ثلاثه اشهر كما ان هناك عشر مدن
اعلنت كمناطق كوارث
هذا وكان اكد وزير الداخليه التركي سليمان
سويلم على انهيار اكثر من 941 منزلا
ودفن 600 شخص من محافظات جنوب تركيا
في محافظه مرعش هدمت
941 مبنا بحصيله اوليه
ويتوقع ان يكون الرقم اعلى من ذلك وحتى
الان دفى الناس 600 شخص من هذه المحافظه
الضوء الضوء
[موسيقى]
وصلتنا هاي البنت مبارح الساعه ثلاثه بعد
الظهر مع كدمات عديده ومع ساحجات كامل
جسمها البنت وجتنا كمان بازيه برد
شديد تم تدفئه التطريع طاقه
سكر ووضع الان مستقبل
[موسيقى]
يعني يعني شيء رعب يعني
[تصفيق]
ساعدني ساعدني يلا يلا يلا
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ومشاهدينا نبدا برصد الاوضاع الميدانيه من
الجانب السوري من الحدود السوريه التركيه
مع الصحفي ابراهيم الادلبي ابراهيم اهلا
بك معنا كيف هو الوضع من عندك في اخر هذه
الساعات الكل يتحدث عن وضع حرج عن منطقه
منكوبه في الشمال السوري ما هي التفاصيل
مساء الخير لك ولجميع المشاهدين من جديد
ارتفعت اعداد الضحايا لتصل الى 970 شخص لك
وحذفه وملاحظ ان هناك زياده منذ الصباح
الباكر حتى الان باعداد الضحايا وذلك بسبب
العمليات المكثفه التي ما زالت مستمره
والتي تقوم بها فرق الدفاع المدني
والمتطوعين بالمناطق المنكوبه المعلومات
الاخيره تؤكد ان مدينه جنديرس بريف عفرين
هي اكثر المدن تضررا هناك بحسب شهود
العيان والتوثيقات اكثر من 80% من المدينه
سوي على الارض على قاطنه لذلك تستمر
عمليات الحفر والنمش للبحث عن ناجين تحت
الانقاذ في مدينه جنديرس بريف عفرين من
على نفس المستوى والصعيد والكارثه
المدنيون الان ما زالوا منتشرين بالعراء
بعض المدنيين المتخوف من العوده الى
المباني المتصدعه والمتشققه ومنهم من خسر
ايضا منزله انهيارات السابقه لذلك الان في
العرائا يجلسون ويحاولون عمليه او الحصول
على القليل من التدفئه من خلال بعض
الاقمشه التي حصلوا عليها بوقت سابق ان
كان من داخل تجمعات المدنيه والسكنيه او
حتى من المنظمات الاغاثيه عمليه النزوح
باتجاه الشمال الشمال السوري باتجاه
الحدود السوريه التركيه ما تزال مستمره مع
ملاحظه امر ان هناك بعض من المدنيين ممن
فقدوا القدره البقاء بالخارج عادوا الى
التجمعات السكنيه مع اخذ تعيين والاعتبار
ان اغلب المناطق هي استضعت لعمليات تشاؤل
الابنيه خضعت لتشقه وقد تهدد بالانهيار
ولكن يبدو انهم وصلوا الى مرحله لا يمكن
البقاء فيها في العراء او في تحت بعيدا عن
المخيم خاصه مع البرد القارس في هذه
المناطق ولكن ابراهيم بالامس كنت حدثتني
عن عمليات التفتيش ومحاوله ايجاد عالقين
او البحث عن عالقين وقلت بانه هذه
او تستخدم طريقه بدائيه للبحث عنهم هل
تغير شيء منذ الامس هل وصلت مساعدات على
الاقل تمكنهم من البحث بطريقه سريعه اكثر
حتى الان لم تصل مساعدات من حدث فقط على
المساعدات والامدادات الداخليه التي لا
تتجه من قريه الى قريه اخرى او من بلده
الى بلده وكل المؤسسات والمنظمات التي
كانت تملك على ثقيله قامت بوضعها تحت تصرف
فرق الدفاع المدني والمتطوعين المدنيين
الذين يحاولون انتشار ولكن نكون صريحين
اكثر وواقعين اليوم يعتمدون في على اليد
البشريه اكثر من الاعلى لان الاله ليست
موجوده في جميع المناطق لذلك التعويل على
المتطوعين وعلى فرق الدفاع المدني التي
تحاول استخدام الادوات الزراعيه في عمليه
تكسير الحجاره او تكسير الصبات الاسمنتيه
في محاوله لابعادها عن اماكن الركام
واستخراج ناجين تحت الانقاب يعتمدون ايضا
على البلاغات المؤكده عن وجود مدنيين او
حتى عن وجود ناجين تحت الانقاذ فبهذه
المرحله جل التركيز على من يتم
او نداء او تسجيل حالي مؤكد يعني وجود
مدنيين فيما ايضا هناك فرق تعمل بشكل عام
على البحث عن ناجين تحت انقاذ مباني لم
يبلغ عنها ولم يبلغ عنه ولكن التركيز كل
التركيز على التبليقات المؤكده لاخراج
المدني من تحت الارض ولكن تقول بانهم
يتصرفون بما لديهم على الاقل من اليات هل
هناك فرق انقاذ فرق متطوعه حاضره على عين
المكان على الاقل المساعده من هم من
متواجدون او من يتواجد على عين المكان هل
هم فقط سكان هذه المنطقه ام هناك ربما فرق
اغاثه اتت مناطق اخرى للمساعده
تحدثت عن عمليه التنقل الاليات الاليات
اليات الحفر واليات التعزيل هذه الاليات
يكون معها فرق متطوعه
تكون قد انجز عملها بمنطقه ما ثم تنتقل
الى منطقه ما ولكن التركيز جل التركيز على
المتطوعين المدنيين قد حدث عن المتطوعين
الذين يساهمون مع فرق الدفاع المدني الذين
يمتلكون خبره اكثر من المتطوع المدني في
عمليه توجيهي بكيفيه العمل وازاله الانقاض
لان المتطوع المدني بالنهايه قد يرتكب خطا
عن غير قصد يؤدي الى وفاه الشخص تحت
الالقاب ذلك عمليه الخبره ووجود فرق
الدفاع المدني ساهمت كثيرا وسهلت عمليه
المتطوعين المدنيين بالنهايه نتحدث عن
معضله او كارثه كبيره حلت
صحيح كارثه كبيره وماساه في الواقع يعيشها
الشمال السوري ابق معي ابراهيم اشير الى
هذا العاجل المشاهدين الملك سلمان وولي
عهد وجهان بتقديم مساعدات عاجله لتركيا
وسوريا اذا كما نرى اسفل الشاشه من خلال
هذا العاجل الملك سلمان وولي العهد وجهاني
بتقديم مساعدات عاجله لتركيا وسوريا تبقى
العين على هذه العواجل طبعا التي
تضعنا في اطار التطورات ان كان من خلال
التصريحات او حتى من خلال
التطورات الميدانيه واعود لك ابراهيم كنت
تحدثت منذ قليل عن صعوبه ليس فقط فيما يخص
عمليه انتشار العالقين ولكن حتى من نفذ ان
صح التعبير من هذا الزلزال وبقي على قيد
الحياه هناك صعوبه كذلك في ايجاد مكان
لاوائه حدثنا اكثر عن الظروف التي يعيشها
السوري شمالا
لنبدا بدرجات الحراره درجات الحراره التي
تقترب من الصفر قد تصل في الليل الى
ذروتها ناقص اثنين الطقس لا يساعد ابدا
على وجود المدنيين في مناطق غير مؤهله او
غير مدفاه في المرحله الثانيه تاتي مشكله
الارض الطينيه التي يتواجد فيها المدنيين
والذين نزحوا باتجاهها لان قبل فتره او
قبل يومين من الزلزال كان هناك عاصفه
ثلجيه ثم تلاها مع الزلزال عاصفه مطريه
صعب عمليه الحركه والتنقل والوصول وحتى
ايضا وضع القماش من اجل الاهتمام من
العاصفه الثلجيه طالما ايضا الارض مبلله
بالسيول الطينيه ايضا كان هناك مشكله
التدفئه مشكله التدفئه هي مشكله سيعاني
منها المدنيون عانى منها وسيستمر معاناتهم
حتى يتم ايجاد حل جذري لهذه المشكله حاليا
خصوصا نحن نتحدث عن عشرات الالاف الذين
يتواجدون في العراء حاليا او بسبب القوم
بالعوده الى منازلهم ومنهم كما تحدث ويعرف
نتيجه المغامره او ما ستؤول اليه نتيجه
فقط ابراهيم ونحن نتحدث الان تتوالى
العواجل في خصوص المساعدات السعوديه كنا
تحدثنا عن الخبر الذي يقول بان الملك
سلمان وهو ولي العهد يوجهان بتقديم
مساعدات عاجله لتركيا
استكمالا لهذا الخبر الملك سلمان ووليه
العهد وجاني بتسير جسر جوي اغاسي لتركيا
وسوريا كذلك يوجهني بارسال فرق انقاذ
بصوره عاجله الى تركيا وسوريا اذا الملك
سلمان وولي عهده وجهاني بتقديم مساعدات
عاجله لتركيا وسوريا كما يوجهني كذلك
بتسير جسر جوي اغاسي لتركي وسوريا
وبارساله فرق انقاذ بصوره عاجله الى هذه
المناطق ابراهيم كنت تتحدث عن صعوبه اي
همم الموجودين هناك نتحدث عن الطقس ولكن
نتحدث كذلك عن ظروف معيشيه صعبه في هذه
المناطق بالاساس كانت هذه المناطق تفتقر
لاقل الاساسيات من تطبيق من محاوله ايجاد
ادوات من تغذيه من
ملابس الى اخره
فهل هناك
ما يحدث او على الاقل هل هناك مساعدات تصل
او وعود بوصولها تكون قريبه من هذه
المناطق
كما تحدثت يا مجرد وعود ولكن وعود غير
مباشره بالنسبه للمدنيين في المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه الجميع يحاول المساعده
بقدر المستطاع الجميع يشغل الجسور الجويه
وينقل المساعدات من اجل ان تصل الى
المدنيين المتضررين ولكن في المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه لها اعتبارات قد تكون
بعض الاحيان والذي حولها النظام
الاعتبارات سياسيه بعيدا عن الكارثه
الانسانيه التي حلت في المنطقه وهي محاوله
تخصيص او محاوله تهميش المنطقه الشماليه
الغربيه من الخطابات التي صدرت مع الساعات
الاولى للزلزال ثم الحديث عن
ان تكون المساعدات عبره دمشق اي هناك
محاوله للالتفاف على الق على القرار
الاممي الذي يقضي بتمديد اليه المساعدات
والذي صوت عليه منذ قرابه الشهر من قبل
مجلس الامن وايضا من الامم المتحده ترعى
هذا الموضوع لذلك تحاول ان يحاول النظام
الالتفال الالتفاف على هذه المساعدات او
محاوله التركيع المنطقه الشماليه ولكن
بعودتنا الى موضوعنا الانسان البحث
والحاله بالنسبه للمدنيه شمال غرب سوريا
دعيني اتحدث عن مشكله جوهريه وهي المواد
الاوليه وماده الخبز كان سابقا قبل
الزلزال هناك عدد من الافراد المركزيه
التي تقدم المدن والقرى في المنطقه
الشماليه الغربيه من سوريا بعد ضرب
الزلزال والرداد الاهتزازيه حصل ان العديد
من الافراد اصبحت خارج الخدمه وانا الكثير
من المدنيين لم تصلهم ماده الخبز منذ منذ
صباح الامس حتى اليوم هناك عدد من
المنظمات الاغاثيه ايضا التي قامت بتقديم
ماده المقاطعه فقط لان هناك صور ردنا
وننشرها لمشاهدينا لنتابعها كذلك هذه
الصور مباشره من ديار بكر اذا نتابع هذه
الصور نتابع حريق هائل وتصاعد لدخان كثيف
في هذه المنطقه
جراء او من تداعيات هذا الزلزال حريق هائل
في الجار بكر جنوب شرق تركيا وهذه
مشاهدينا صور مباشره تاتينا من ديار بكر
جنوب شرق تركيا نتحدث عن ساعات بعد هذا
الزلزال الذي هز كل من جنوب تركيا وشمال
سوريا واودى بحياه المئات
وضحايا بالالاف وهناك طبعا دعوات للمساعده
في اخر هذه التصريحات استكمالا لما كنا
تحدثنا بخصوص منذ قليل همم كذلك الملك
سلمان وولي العهد وجيهاني مركز الملك
سلمان بتسير جسر جوي ويوجهان بتنظيم حمله
شعبيه عبر منصه ساهم لدعم تركيا
وسوريا ونحن نبقى في متابعه هذه الصور
وكذلك في رصد اخر الاخبار واخر التطورات
الخاصه بالظروف ظروف عمليات انتشار
العالقين وكذلك ظروف
محاوله ايجاد سكن للبعث الذي لم يجد مكانا
يسكن فيه خاصه في ساعات تعيش فيها هذه
المناطق حاله صعبه
مشاهدينا سنكتفي بهذا القدر مع ابراهيم
الادلبي الصحفي من على الحدود السوريه
التركيه من الجانب السوري اشكرك جزيل
الشكر ابراهيم واتابع مع ضيفي من القاهره
مدير المرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان رامي
عبد الرحمن سيد رامي اهلا بك معنا نقف معك
على اخر
الاخبار التي تردك حضرتك تحدثت عن ارتفاع
في اعداد الضحايا واعداد الجرحى كذلك
فحدثنا اكثر عما رصدتموه في الساعات
الاخيره
في الدقائق الاخيره مساء الخير في الدقائق
الاخيره لان الساعات هي ارقام مختلفه
حقيقه الامر منطقه جنديرس في عفرين يعني
هناك كارثه حقيقيه في هذه المنطقه اليوم
نشرنا الصور من تلك المنطقه نتحدث عن
المئات مئات العائلات قتلت في تلك المنطقه
ولا يزال هناك الكثير من المفقودين نحو
200 منزل تضرروا نحو تفعيل منزل يعني
دمروا بشكل كامل في تلك المنطقه نتحدث عن
رقم ليس لا نقول الرقم غير نهائي نقول رقم
اولي حتى اللحظه لان هناك الفين والاثنان
وثمانون
الى هذه اللحظه لبعض اللحظات لنصحح خبر
كنا او ردناه منذ قليل وضحت الصوره اكثر
نحن نتحدث عن حريق في ميناء اسكندرون بعد
اعلان وزاره الدفاع التركيه اخماده قبل
قليل هي ليست صور مباشره وانما صور مسجل
يريدنا الان وننشرها
لمشاهدينا اذا تجدد الحريق في ميناء
اسكندرون بعد اعلان وزاره الدفاع التركيه
اخماده قبل قليل نبقى مع هذه الصور ابقى
معنا استاذ عبد الرحمن رامي واعود لي او
اذهب الى اضنه
العربيه زيدان اهلا بك معنا اسوره من عندك
نعم ريما قبل خمس دقائق بالضبط وصلنا الى
هذا المكان في شارع هذا البناء الذي
تشاهدونه الان هو كان او هذا الركام كان
لبناء مكون من
14 طالقا حسبما اخبرنا به رجال الانقاذ
قبل قليل لدى وصولنا كنا نسال احد رجال
الانقاذ عن عدد الاشخاص الموجودين تحت
الركام قالوا انهم لا يعلمون لكن لكن
يسمعون اصواتا من الداخل لذلك سيحاولون
الوصول الى هؤلاء الاشخاص العالقين ايضا
استفسرنا عن عدد الاشخاص الذين خرجوا
احياء من هذا المبنى قال انهم استطاعوا
خلال منذ يوم امس وحتى اليوم اخراج خمسه
اشخاص لكن قبل ان اكون معكم على الهواء
مباشره سمعنا اصوات تكبير من عمال الانقاذ
والطواقب الموجوده هنا وعلمنا ان شخص اخر
على قيد الحياه استطاعوا تقريبا الوصول
اليه وهو ما يزال على قيد الحياه
والمحاولات تجري الان بكثافه وكل العمال
الذين كانوا او الطواقم التي كانت موجوده
هنا في المنطقه سارعت للمشاركه بعمليات
اخراج الركام والكتل الخرسانيه للوصول الى
هذا الشخص الناجي الذي ان شاء الله ربما
ان كنا معكم سنستطيع رصد عمليه اخراجه على
الهواء او اخراجه على الهواء مباشره طبعا
وصلنا اضنه قبل حوالي ساعه من الان او نصف
ساعه من الان لدى وصولنا من مطار اضنه
يتحدث بشكل عام عما شاهدناه منذ لحظه
وصولنا الى الان
طائرات مساعدات يقتض بها مطار اضنه شهد
طائرات من مصر من الجزائر من الاردن من
الهند رومانيا وايضا من اسبانيا كلها
طائرات تحمل مساعدات الى تركيا وايضا
شاهدنا العديد من الطواقم المختصه طواقم
الانقاذ التي وصلت الى اضنه تصل الى هنا
الى هذه الولايه ومن ثم يتم توزيع الكوادر
الرقم الى باقي الولايات المنكوبه
الولايات التسعه المنكوبه طبعا هذا اليوم
نائب الرئيس التركي فؤاد اوكتاي قال ان
مطار اضنه بات مطار اللوجستيان وبالتالي
حركه الوصول الى هذا المطار من بقيه
الولايات اسهل لكن
حتى الان وكما علمنا اثناء وجودنا في
المطار المشكله هي الساعات على الانتظار
التي يقضيها بعض او تقضيها بعض الطواقم
لحين الوصول الى المناطق المنكوبه او
المناطق التي يريدون الوصول اليها بسبب
احيانا اما للظروف الجويه التي هي سيئه
بطبيعه الحال او واما للدمار في بعض الطرق
التي
دمرها الزلزال الطرق بين الولايات التركيه
في الجنوب التركي طبعا
لما تقول بان هناك صعوبه في وصول هذه
المعدات وهذه المساعدات فقط اشير زيدان
الى اننا سنبقى معك ومع هذه الصور
المباشره لعمليات الانتشار المستمره
لعالقين وتقول بانه في الساعات الاخيره تم
انتشار العالقين على قيد الحياه وهذا ما
يتمناه الكل في الواقع ولكن زيدان حدثتني
عن ان هناك صعوبات في اصول المساعدات
صعوبات تتعلق بالطقس
بالطرقات فهل تصل بطريقه مستمره او هناك
توقف لبعض الوقت وفيما بعد تثتكمل العمليه
كيف تتم وما الذي يصل يعني ما نوع
المساعدات التي تصل في هذه الساعات
الاخيره
نعم لا شك ان بالدرجه الاولى هناك شقين
للمساعدات اولا
الاليات او القسم الاول هو بشكل عاجل
تحاول السلطات ايصاله الى المناطق
المنكوبه الاليات والطواقم التي ستشارك في
عمليات التنقيب عفوا او عمليات البحث عن
ناجين تحت الانقاض وازاله الركام لذلك هذا
هو الشق الاول طبعا اضافه للطواقم البشريه
هناك معدات ضروريه معدات حفر
معدات حفر مطلوبه لهذه الطواقم واليات
تستطيع ازاله الكتل الخرسانيه ايضا يجب
ايصال هذه
الاليات الى المناطق المنكومه المنكوبه
عفوا واضافه طبعا الى اطقم الاسعاف
والسيارات الاسعاف التي يجب ان تساعد ان
تخلي الجرحى او المصابين الى المستشفيات
القريبه هذا الشق الاول من المعونات
المطلوبه لطواقم الانقاذ اشقت الاخر وهو
المعونات المطلوبه لسكان المدن العشره او
الولايات العشره الذين يبيتون في اماكن
اللواء المؤقته اولا او حتى في الشوارع او
في اماكن عامه او مثلا في الحدائق المطلوب
لهؤلاء ويجري العمل عليه بسرعه
عدد كبير من الخيام الاف الخيام ايضا
معونات من اغطيه شتى والبسه شتويه وايضا
اطعمه وادويه لكبار السن للاطفال طبعا كل
هذه المعونات تحاول السلطات التركيه
تسييرها بشكل سريع الرئيس التركي اليوم
اليوم تحدث عن اكثر من 54 الف خيمه تم
ارسالها الى الجنوب التركي لكن حتى الان
يبدو ان هناك حاجه اكبر لعدد اكبر سواء
للخيام او حتى للبطانيات او للالبسه
الشتويه كل هذا الموضوع تحاول السلطات
التركيه تامينه خلال وقت قصير طبعا من
النقاط الاخرى التي تريد السلطات التركيه
تامينها لزياده عدد اماكن الايواء لذلك
هناك مخطط حكومي لنقل اعداد كبيره من
السكان الموجودين هنا في الجنوب التركي
الذين بقوا دون ماوى الى فنادق في مناطق
بعيده عن هذه الاماكن الخطر
وحدد الرئيس
سابقى معك تبقى معنا هذه الصوره المباشره
لمتابعه عمليه انتشال العالق وابقى معي
للحظات ساذهب الى الجانب السوري او للحديث
عن الجانب السوري مع الاستاذه رامي عبد
الرحمن سيد رامي الوضع في تركيا صعب ولكن
الوضع في سوريا كارثه خاصه بالنسبه
للمناطق التي لا تصلها مساعدات وليست هناك
اخبار دقيقه بخصوصها سيد رامي ضعنا في
اطار ما يحدث في المناطق التي تتبع للنظام
وخاصه في المناطق التي تاتينا منها اخبار
متضاربه وهي المناطق التي تسيطر عليها
المعارضه كيف هي تفاصيل وكيف هو الوضع
هناك
ساتابع على موضوع جنديرس جنديرس هي الان
المنطقه الاكثر ايلاما وكرفيه حقيقه الامر
من ضمن تفعيل مبنى تهدموا بشكل كامل تمت
مساعده 12 مبنى او عشره مباني لا نعلم
انقاذ او اخراج الجثامين من داخل هذه
المنطقه هناك مئات الضحايا في هذه البلده
الصغيره في منطقه عفرين هناك شكاوي كثير
من السكان في جنديرس وسكان عفرين وهناك
بعض السوريين المهجرين الى تلك المنطقه
قال ذهبنا الى القاعده التركيه طلبنا
مساعده في عمليه الانقاص رفضوا ان
يساعدونا ساعدنا انفسنا كان هناك محاوله
تجمع اهالي في محاوله انقاذ العالقين يعني
اتركوا هؤلاء تحت الانقاذ الى الانقاذ الى
يعني مصيرهم وايضا في حلب على سبيل المثال
النظام تحدث عن انهيار مباني في حلب هناك
مئات المباني التي انهارت بشكل كامل عدد
الضحايا المؤ حتى اللحظه والغير النهائي
الفان واثنان وثمانون ضحيه قتلوا نتيجه
الزلزال الكبير ونتيجه التامر حقيقه الامر
لا نعلم بالمال من النظام السوري الذي
يعني تباطا بفتح فتح المعابر الدوليه من
المجتمع الدولي الذي تحدث اعلاميا عن
الايصال مساعدات الى الشعب السوري لماذا
ولكن هل هذه المعابر فتحت لانه حتى معبر
بالهواء مثلا كانت هناك كان هناك تضارب
بخصوص فتحه من عدم ذلك فيما يقول البعض
بانه تم الفاتح ولكن هناك صعوبه في ايصال
المساعدات البعض الاخر يقول بان عمليه
وصول مساعدات توقفت
ادعينا من معبر باب الهوى معبر باب الهوى
قالوا الاتراك بان هناك صعوبه نتيجة
الزلزال والى اخره ولكن الدوليه الامم
المتحده الصليب الاحمر جميع المنصبات هناك
امكانيه لايصال المساعدات ليس براي النظام
العدميه هذه قضيه انسانيه نحن نتحدثنا وكل
لحظه نتحدث المزيد من الضحايا لماذا
الانسان السوري المواطن السوري رخيص لهذه
الدرجه لماذا لا تفتح مطار اللاذقيه
لاستقبال الطائرات طائرات المساعدات ولكن
لا تفهم لشبيحه بشار الاسد وغيرهم
تجرين من ابناء الشعب السوري بحمايه الامم
المتحده داخل الاراضي السوريه تدخل الى
ادلب تدخل الى ريف حلب وتدخل الى مناطق
النظام في حلب وغيرها لان ابناء الشعب
السوري الذين قتلوا لم يكونوا معارضه في
مناطق المعارضه ولا موالات في مناطق
الموالاه هم ابناء شعب سوري هم مدنيين كل
لحظه نتاخر فيها مزيد من الجثث تستخرج من
تحت الانقاد وايضا مفيد من الجثث
نعم ولك سيدي عبد الرحمن اولا المواطن
السوري ليس رخيص بالعكس هو غالي وغالي جدا
والمساعدات قيل بانه هناك محاوله لايصالها
حضرتك تقول بان هذه المساعدات لن تصل بعد
ولكن هل هناك جهود على الاقل هل رصدت
حضرتك او رصد فريقك اي جهود لمحاوله ايصال
هذه المساعدات من جانب النظام السوري
والبعض يقول حتى بان المناطق المتضرره من
الجانب يعني جانب النظام الذي او التي
تسيطر
عليه قوات النظام السوري ليست باحسن حال
باسواق حار هي الموضوع الموضوع قبل
الزلزال في مناطق الي صار مع عشرات المرات
تحدثنا عن العربيه والحدث بان هناك وضع
انساني كارثي بشكل كبير جدا الان يعني
نقرا على الشاشه بان مصر المساعدات
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه والامارات
العربيه المتحده ودول كثيره نريد من هذه
المساعدات ان تصل الى مستحقيها ولا تسلم
للنظام السوري يجب ان تسلم الى مستحقيها
تصل الى مستحقيها هناك فرق من هذه الدول
من الممكن ان تصل الى حلب الى اللاذقيه
الى ادلب الى ريف حلب انا اقول لك يعني
ماذا ننتظر ان نستخرج او لا الذين تحت
الانقاض
طائرات تصل في في تركيا يقول بان الطائرات
تصل تباعا الى مطارات تركيا لكن بشار
الاسد ماذا ينتصر ينتصر ان يموت مزيد من
السوريين حتى تصل مساعدتك سيد رامي على كل
سنبقى في متابعه كل هذه التفاصيل في ساعات
القادمه نعلم بان كل ساعه كل دقيقه مهمه
جدا لانقاذ هذه الارواح رامي عبد الرحمن
مدير مرصد السوري لحقوق الانسان كنت معنا
من القاهره شكرا جزيلا لك
تلو الاخرى هذا هو الحال في مدينه حلب بعد
زلزال نتابع
يعني كل خمس دقايق بجينا اربع خمس اشخاص
الله يرحمهم ويعني ما عاد لحقنا ومستمرين
بالشغل نحن يعني هلا اليوم الصبح لهلا صار
تجوز العدد فوق الخمسين
الله يرحمهم فتاخر علينا الدفن لانه جسد
طلعت مي مع بعضها في وقت في مسافه يعني
الساعه 11:30 بالليل
حاولنا انه نجمع الجثث ندفنهم فردا مثل ما
شايفين هلا هون في معنا ايداع الجثه
وبعدنا
والله
بدي اروح معهم
ونتابع استطلاع الاوضاع من الارض معنا من
القميش جمعه كاش مراسل العربيه جمعه اهلا
بك معنا الوضع من عندك في هذه الساعات
الاخيره الكل يتحدث عن وضع حرج للغايه ما
هي تفاصيله
نعم
الوقت يتعقد المشهد هنا اكثر
فاكثر لاسمه بالنسبه لمئات السوريين الذين
لا يزالون يقضون برد الشتاء وعطمه الان
تحت ركام المنازل
المدمره جهود الانقاذ فيما يبدو لن تستطيع
انتشال اها او لا احياء لان الفرص بدات
تستنفذ فعليا يعني تصوري اكثر من يعني 35
ساعه بدون اكل بدون شرب في كل هذا الهلع
في هذا البرد كيف يمكن للمئات ان ينجوا
بحياه لذلك يعني فعلا يعني عندما يتم
استخراج اطفال او او نساء او حتى رجال
متاحه هذه الالقاب بعد مرور كل هذا الوقت
في وجه هذا الدمار وهذا الموت الذي بدا
يحصد يعني حياه حوالي 2000 سوري على عموم
يعني الجغرافيا السوريه خاصه في المدن
الرئيسيه حلب اللاذقيه ادلب وحمام
ونحن تابع دائما كل هذا فقط نشير الى ان
منذ قليل
جمعه كانت هناك هزه ارضيه جديده بقوه خمس
درجات في كهرمان مرعى الجنوبيه تركيا من
الجانب التركي
جمعه هناك منظمات انقاذ ومنظمات اغاثه
تحاول في الواقع الوصول والعمل في هذه
المناطق المناطق المناطق المنكوبه من
الاساس والتي تفتقد لادنى اساسيات الحياه
فهل شاهدت او هل وصلك او بلغك تفاصيل
بلغتك تفاصيل عن محاوله على الاقل تقديم
مساعده اللازمه فيما يخص هذه المناطق
يعني مساله المساعدات تحتاج الى رؤيه اوسع
يعني الجميع يعلم بان النظام السوق خذ من
المجتمع الدولي ولا احد يعني يطبع او
يتعامل معه
العربيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي امريكا هذه
دول قاطعت النظام السوري لكن يعني المطلوب
في الحاله السوريه في هذه الكارثه ان يتم
يعني ايجاد الي في مؤقته مجدوله بجداول
زمنيه محدده للتعامل يعني اليوم كان هناك
اتصال من الرئيس المصري لا توجد دول عربيه
يعني هذه المساعدات الدوليه في حال لو هدف
على سوريا
يجب ان تمر عبر المنافذ التي تسيطر عليها
النظام سوى المطار دمشق الدولي او حلب او
اللاذقيه او حتى الموانئ في بانياس
والساحل بشكل بشكل عام لذلك نحن نفسر بان
هذه
يعني لا الى سوريا يعني فقط من العراق من
ايران وبشكل محدود من
الجزائر وطائره اماراتيه هبطت في مطار
دمشق حوالي اربع ساعات لكن هناك سبعه
واربعين دوله وعدت بتقديم المساعدات الى
السوريين هناك دائما يعني لقط حول المعبر
باب الهوى اود ان اؤكد يعني المعبر
الاساسي مناطق شمال غرب سوريا وتركيا هذا
المعبر مفتوح ولم يتم اغلاقه رسميا لكنه
غير مفعل لاسباب عده ابرزها وجود
وجود طرقات معطله تؤدي اليه وايضا قربوا
من مركز الزلزال لان المناطق الجنوبيه في
تركيا يعني تمر بها عاده المساعدات الى
مناطق المعارضه اي مناطق شمال غرب سوريا
لكن هذا المعبر مفتوح ولم يغلق لاي قرارات
لكنه غير غير مفعل ايضا ريم دعيني اؤكد
بان المنظمات الدوليه يعني حاولت ان تنشر
على عدد المواقع والقنوات التلفزه بانها
تعمل في مناطق ادب عبر شركاء محليين انا
اتواصل بشكل يعني كل دقيقه وكل ساعه مع
النشاطاء المدنيين وايضا مع الدفاع المدني
لا توجد اي مساعده خارجيه وصلت الى
المناطق المنكوبه في شمال غرب سوريا صحيح
هناك منظمات محليه لربما تعتقد الامم
المتحده
شركاء على الارض حتى هذه المنظمات يعني لا
تستطيع يعني الاخاطى بحتى بثلاثه في الميه
من احتياجات السكان لا في مناطق المعارضه
ولا حتى في المناطق المفتوحه اصلا امامها
في مناطق النظام يعني كان هناك سلات
غذائيه تم توزيعها من قبل مفوضيه شؤون
اللاذقيه
نتحدث عن 7 مليون انسان متضررين
والحاله ماساويه الحقيقه بعد قليل جمعه
سيكون معنا احد العاملين في فرق الانقاص
سنسال كذلك عن كل هذه التفاصيل شكرا جزيلا
لك جماعه عكاش من القمش لزمينا من جندريس
الان من ريف حلب عاطف نعنوع عن مدير
التنفيذيه لفريق ملهم التطوعي سيد عاطف
اهلا بك معنا سيد عاطف نتابع على صفحتكم
على تويتر مجموعه كبيره من الاعمال وكذلك
من
البرامج التطوعيه التي تقومون بها وانتم
حاضرون حدثنا اكثر اين تتمركزون وما هي
خططكم للمساعده
مساء الخير اهلا بك قتلى
ان شاء الله هيك الدفاع المدني والمتطوعين
على يعني
ابقاء اكبر عدد ممكن من الاحياء اللي هنا
تحت الانقاب من حوالي 72 ساعه بالنسبه
لشغلنا كفريقنا متطوعين فريق ذاتي يعني
منظمه ملخص الاكثر من دوله حول العالم
تشتغل بالشمال السوريه دول اللجوء تركيا
لبنان الاردن
للاسف يعني مرينا كوارث قصه حصار لانه
كارثه الزلزال الغير متوقع اثناء عاصفه
ثلجيه بهذا الوقت
يعني بلحظه وجود كل العائلات تحت اسقف
نايمين
يعني كل المعطيات ادت لك كارثه جدا جدا
كبيره حتى تاخر
فتره الصدمه بالنسبه للناس
لحتى يكتشفوا حجم الكارثه او حتى بالنسبه
للاعلام وحتى بالنسبه للمنظمات العالم
سواء على المدن التركيه او المدن السوريه
ولكن
بالنسبه للمدن السوريه وصلتم لادلب لحلب
مثلا متواجدون نحن انا متواجد
اكثر الاماكن اكثر الاستاذ قبليني
الكامله تحت الانقاض لحد اللحظه في مباني
متروكه بسبب انشغالهم
يعتقد انه اللي تحت احياء ما زالوا
الحمدلله
موجودون انتم عاداتكم كم
وتتعاملوا مع من كيف تخططون كيف تسعوبات
خاصه
حاليا موجود في عدد المنظمات امبارح كان
لسه صدمه موجود
المطوعين من الناس
اكبر بس توصل المساعدات من قبل المناطق
المجاوره
بعض الاليات للاسف الحاجه اكبر المعدات
نحن بحاجه لمعدات متطوره اكثر بحاجه
لخبراء اكثر الدفاع المدني ما شاء الله
عنه شغال بس الدفاع المدني ممكن لما يكون
في مركز بمدينه يكون في قصف لطائره او قصف
مدفعي مثلا في الهدايه مبنى مبني عن عشرات
المباني حاليا فبالتالي 8 مراكز اجت من
المناطق الثانيه متطوعين كثير مدنيين اللي
جابوا المعدات اليدويه اللي عندهم اياها
بالبيت او اللي هن حسب كل واحد طبيعه عمله
بيشتغل ما في كهرباء وبالتالي انت لما
بتحتاجي
يعني شيء حديد الالات اصل حديد تحتاج الى
خاصه يعني نتحدث عن فقد الاليات ام
معك صعوبه ممكن تخطر على بال اي انسان في
العالم ما انا موجود بالمنطقه احنا بنحكي
عن الزلزال اثناء عاصفه ثلجيه بمنطقه
منكوبه تحتوي على على على ناجحين وسكان
اصليين بتحتوي على مباني
مؤقتا اصابت الدائره مقياس سبعه ونص درجه
راح اختار فبالتالي الدمار هائل لا يكاد
يشبه اي يعني منطقه ثانيه بتوقع
للاسف الناس هم بحجر المي بحاجه للاكل
بحاجه للشباب بحاجه لكل شيء بحاجه
منظمات المجتمع مدني
الوضع صعب
[موسيقى]
بمنطقه اكثر من منكوبه
ما في ما فينا الان للامانه الرصيف
اشخاص
بياخذه ويمشي مغطيين بحرامات
المناظر الي عم نشوفها عشنا
حصار كل الامور الا انه
هاي الكارثه يعني لا توصف للامانه يعني
حرفيا لانه الناس هاينا بتحس القيامه يعني
كانه يوم القيامه
وهكذا وصفها البعض فعلا الله يكون في عون
الناس الله يكون في عونكم نبقى في متابعه
كل هذا اود شكرك جزيل الشكر على المشاركه
معنا عاطف نعنوع المدير وتنفيذي لفريق
ملهم التطوعي شكرا جزيلا لك
نتابع دائما مع ضيفنا الان من واشنطن
الدكتور امجد راس رئيس جمعيه الطبيه
السوريه الامريكيه سامر اهلا بك معنا
دكتور دكتور كيف تتابع الحاله الكارثيه
الماساويه نتحدث عن تركيا ولكن نتحدث عن
سوريا بشقيها
للاسف نقولها لان هناك مناشدات
لوصول
المساعدات الى داخل المناطق التي تسيطر
عليها المعارضه
كيف هي مشاهداتك وما الصعوبات
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله شكرا لاستضافتي
انا بحيي اول شيء العميل على الارض
البيض اخي عاطف نعنوع منظمه ملهم تطوع
بقوموا باعمال جباره والاخرين طبعا في
غياب نظام اسعافي واضح
له قياده مركزيه الكل عم يقوم باللي بقدر
عليه نحن كمنظمه طبيه نعمل في شمال سوريا
وندير
حوالي خمسين بالميه من المشايخ الطبيه
الحقيقه اللي صار فوق الخيال مثل ما وصف
وصفه المتحدثين
بندور قليل
اللي عم نشوفه هلا هو
نقص
بالتجهيزات الاسعاف من ناحيه اول شيء من
ناحيه انقاذ الجراحه من تحت الانقاض
اللي عم يكون فيها التشغيل الخوذ البيض
ما فيهم طبعا المطاوعين وبدانا حتى بعد
تحريك
مخزون من مستودعاتنا الى مشافي نحن بدانا
نشوف نقص بالموعد مع الجراحيه نعم تفضل
بقى معي ساعود لك ربما بعد قليل اسمح لي
فقط على المقاطعه سنعود لما كنا اوردناه
منذ قليل مشاهدينا في عواجلنا حيث وجه
العاهل السعودي الملك سلمان بن عبد العزيز
ولي العهد الامير محمد بن سلمان وجه مركز
الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه
بتسير جسر جوي الى تركيا وسوريا وتقديم
مساعدات صحيه وايوائيه وغذائيه لتخفيف
اثار الزلزال كما وجه الملك سلمان والامير
محمد سلمان بتنظيمي حمله شعبيه عبر منصه
ساهم لمساعده الضحايا هذا الزلزال ونقف
اكثر على تفاصيل هذا الخبر مع ضيفنا من
الرياض الدكتور سامر الجليطي المتحدث باسم
مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال
الانسانيه دكتور اهلا بك معنا تابعنا هذا
الخبر تبعنا التفاصيل التي اتت بعد
الاعلان عن هذه المساعدات والتسريع بها
ولكن تكلمنا عن التفاصيل هل هناك خطه
زمنيه هذه المساعدات تتضمن ماذا بتحديد
حياكم الله احييكم واحيانا الكرام
لعلي اذا سمحتي لو صحح اسم الاخير انا
الدكتور سامر الجطيلي اهلا وسهلا
العفو الله يطول عمرك الحقيقه ان هذه
المساعدات هذه
الامين تاتي للوقوف مع الاشقاء في سوريا
وكذلك في تركيا جراء هذا الحادث الاليم
وهذه الكارثه الكبيره الحقيقه لكل
المعايير نعم الان مركز الملك سلمان وضع
خطه
للتدخل الانساني عاجل يركز على الاحتياجات
الاساسيه خلال المرحله الاوليه مرحله
التدخل الاولي او ما يسمى بالتدخل
الانساني العاجل هذه المرحله سوف تشمل
الحقيقه تقديم
سلال غذائيه او الحقيقه الحرص كل الحرص
على تامين الاحتياجات في مجال القطاع
الغذائي كذلك القطاع الاخر هو اولويه قصوى
هو قطاع
ميمي الخيام وكذلك
الحقيبه الايوائيه المعياريه التي يقدمها
عاده مركز الملك سلمان خلال هذه الازمات
وكذلك بالاضافه الى ذلك الحقيقه حقيبه
الشتويه ليقدمها كذلك في الحقيقه في فتره
الشتاء هناك كذلك اهتمام كبير جدا
بالاحتياجات في المجال الطبي تامين
الاحتياجات سواء كانت من ادويه او سواء
الوريديه او غيرها بحيث تشد الاحتياج
تساعد الحقيقه في نوعا ما تامين الاستقرار
للحاله الصحيه الى المتضررين في هذه
الفتره مع هذا الجحر مزوي الذي تنطلق باذن
الله عز وجل وتم تجهيز تحقيق الكبير منه
سوف يكون هناك فريق يقيم الاحتياج على
الارض
واضاعه كذلك خطه اخرى لتدخل اكبر باذن
الله عز وجل ولكن
مكون فريق مكون من من يعني من مختصين
اطباء من من
الفريق الحقيقه يحتوي عدد من الجهات كما
تفضلتم فريق طبي الحقيقه يعنى بمجال
العلاجات الاسعافيه
والجراحيه هناك كذلك فريق من الدفاع
المدني للانقاذ ومتخصص في انقاذ في مثل
هذه الحالات وكذلك لدينا فريق لوجستي من
المركز سوف يقوم برفع الاحتياجات عن قرب
وكذلك
محاوله وضع خطه اكثر دقه واكثر شمول
لمرحله ما نسميها التعافي المبكر ولعلنا
كذلك باذن الله عز وجل نهدف الى ما هو
اكبر من ذلك نهدف باذن الله عز وجل الى
مرحله اعاده البناء واعاده تاجيل المنازل
المتضرره وكذلك اعاده الحياه الى طبيعتها
في تلك المناطق هذه المساعدات تهبط في اي
مطار وستتوجه لايت مناطق
سوف اتحدث المطارات الاقرب لمناطق
الاحتياج بالتنسيق مع السلطات التركيه
وكذلك
السلطات المعنيه باداره هذه الازمه
والكارثه
طبعا قد تكون مرشحه المطارات المنشاه
المرشحه مثلا اقرب هي اضانه اذا كان صالح
للاستخدام او ربما مطار انطاكيا وهو اقرب
كذلك من مناطق القريبه من الحدود السوريه
الان هناك تنسيق جاري عليه المستوى مع
الجهات التركيه لعده امور الحقيقه اولا
كما تفضلتم الجانب الثاني الحقيقه متعلق
بايصال هذه المساعدات المتضررين في
المناطق السوريه والتي تعتبر تركيا هي
المفتاح الحقيقه وهي المدخل لهذه المناطق
فهناك تنسيق الان على مستغيين الحقيقه دعم
عمليات الانقاذ وذلك عن طريق الحقيقه دعم
كل من يعمل الان على
افهم افهم من حضرتك انا كنت تتواصلون مع
السلطات التركيه لمحاوله ايجاد حلول
لادخال هذه المساعدات للشمال السوري هذا
صحيح وكذلك مع اي جهات الحقيقه هي تملك
مفتاح للوصول لتلك المناطق
نتحدث كذلك عن حمله شعبيه حمله ساهم
للمساعده لمن هو بعيد
ويود ان يساعد كيف تتم المساعده لو نفهم
معك اكثر هذه الخطه
منصه سهم منصه رقميه
تعنى اطلاقها مركز الملك سلمان من حوالي
ثلاث سنوات هذه المنصه الحقيقه فيها
محورين مهمين جدا محور المشاريع الثابته
التي يمكن ان يتبرع لها اي شخص يريد ان
يصل الى المحتاجين من خلال قنوات تبرع
البطاقات او غيرها كذلك لدينا المحور
الاخر محور اللي هو الكوارث او الطوارئ
الحقيقه نحن من خلال هذه المنصه بحمد الله
عز وجل هذه السنه جمعنا مئات الملايين
للفيضانات في باكستان فيضانات في السودان
وكذلك المجاعه في الصومال وما زلنا نجمع
ستطلق حمله من خلال هذه المنصه تمكن كل من
يريد ان يوصل شيء للمحتاجين ان يتبرع لهم
في قطاع الغذاء وقطاع الايواء قطاع كذلك
القطاع الصحي كذلك لدينا حسابات بنكيه سوف
تنشر وهي مشهوره حاليا على منصه ساهم
وكذلك لدينا وسائل وهي رسائل الرسائل
النصيه التي يمكن ان يتبرع من خلالها
الحقيقه ان مركز الملك سلمان يحاول النصيه
للموجودين داخل المملكه العربيه السعوديه
طبعا ولكن دكتور بالنسبه لهذه الحمله
لمنصه ساهم الحمله بدات صحيح يعني من يود
الان اتبرع هو قادر على ذلك
الحلم تنطلق غدا الساعه وحده ظهرا باذن
الله عز وجل وسيكون لها تدشين اعلاميه
وتغطيه اعلاميه داخل مركز الملك سلمان
وسوف يكون عدد حضور من مهتمين الحقيقه
بالعمل الانساني وستكون الانطلاقه الساعه
1:00 ظهرا باذن الله عز وجل هذا فيما يخص
سهم اعود معك للمساعدات قلت لي انا هذه
المساعدات قادره على الوصول او يعني ان
تحط طائرات
في المطارات التي ستجدونها الانسب في اي
وقت في غضون اي وقت
المفترض انطلق خلال 24 ساعه
الحقيقه تم حشد الموارد وتحريك الموارد
الموجوده في المستودعات نحن اريد ان اذكر
انه ليست المره الاولى التي نتعامل مع
يعني الجسور الجويه نحن اطلقنا عدد من
الجسور الجويه خلال الكورونا في عدد من
الدول المتضرره حملت مساعدات كبيره جدا
كالاكسجين وغيرها من المستلزمات الطبيه
والادويه الى تقريبا 32 دوله كذلك نحن
سيارنا الجسر الدولي لباكستان الجوي في
السودان وكذلك الحقيقه جسر جوي
لتونس خلال ازمه كورونا كذلك جسر جوي
لمريقه
وخبره في الحقيقه سرعه وكذلك الحقيب من
خلال الجسر جسور الجويه وكذلك لدينا مواد
الحقيقه احتياط دائما في الاحتياط موجوده
نستطيع تحريكها في اي لحظه في حال وجود
هناك طارئ او كارثه نعم بالتوفيق لكم
دكتور سامر الجطيلي المتحدث باسم مركز
الملك سلمان للاغاثه والاعمال الانسانيه
شكرا جزيلا لك
اعود من جديد الى ضيفه من واشنطن عبر زوم
الدكتور امجد راس رئيس جمعيه الطبيه
السوريه الامريكيه سامر دكتور من جديد
اهلا بك معنا
مساعدات تصل مساعدات اخرى في طريقها
للوصول مساعدات اخرى تتحذر
لمحاوله ايجاد سبل
لوصولها في ظل صعوبات بالغه خاصه في ما
يهم منطقه الشمال السوري حدثنا اكثر عن
الصعوبات التي رصتموها
الحقيقه هي الصعوباتها الان
[موسيقى]
من ناحيه طبيه طبعا نقص المستهلكات
والمواد الجراحيه لاسعاف المرضى بالمرحله
الاولى من الاسعاف طبعا هذا استجابه
للكوارث لعده مراحل ما حيقولوا هي انقاذ
الارواح فنحن نحن كمنظمه عامله
نشعر نشوف بنفس المستهلكات
وبشكر كل شيء كل واحد كل منظم دوله وما
فيهم منظمه عفوا هيئه
لانجازاتها بالماضي ومساعدتها للشعب
السوري وندعو الاخرين
لمسجد العون لكن في عقابه نحن هلا
سامحني ستعذرني لان هناك كلمه لوزير
الخارجيه تركيا مولود شاويش اوبنون وتابع
تك
لا زالت تقدم خدمتها وكذلك الفرق
المتواجده خارج البلاد ايضا
نقوم بكل جهودها لتذليل وصولهم الى هذه
المناطق التي تعرضت لكارثه
ليقوم يشرعوا باعمالهم فيها حتى الان ما
يزيد على ثلاث
الاف3319 فردا يعملون في
فرق الانقاذ وكذلك
من دول اخرى
جاري العمل لتبديل انتقالهم الى منطقه
الكوارث وايضا لانشاء مستشفى ميداني
يرسلون سيتم ارسال معدات اللازمه لمستشفى
ميداني من قبل المنظمات الدولي والدول
الاخرى ايضا تصلنا مساعدات عينيه من دول
العالم المختلفه ونبذل جهدنا لتنسيق هذه
المرحله
والكثير من نظرائنا من وزاره الخارجيه من
دول العالم اتصلوا بنا ليعربوا عن اسفهم
ويعزون اشكرهم جدا كما اعلنا الحداد وايضا
جمهوريه قبرص الشماليه التركيه وكذلك وسوف
اعلنت الحداد
وايضا العديد منظمات الدوليه منظمات الدول
التركيه في حلف الناتو وغيرها
اصدروا قرارا بنكسل العلم الى المنتصف
تضامنا مع تركيا اشكرهم لذلك طبعا بينما
تستمر اعمال البحث والانقاذ في الميدان في
الساحه
[موسيقى]
المواطنين الذين هدمت بيوتهم ومداوات
الجرحى كل مؤسساتنا وكل اجهزه الدوله في
حاله استنفاق
السيد رئيس الجمهوريه وسيد نائب رئيس
الجمهوريه
بتصريحات حول كم المساعدات التي تم القيام
بها لكن خارج مناطق الكوارث ايضا في
المحافظات الاخرى
ايضا
لتوفير الايوائي في المحافظات الاخرى غير
المحافظات التي تعرضت لكارثه بدانا
اعمالنا ضمن التوجيهي السيد رئيس
الجمهوريه
بينما السيد وزير السياحه والثقافه محمد
نوري يوجه اعماله في ملاطيا فكذلك في
منطقه
مارسين وانطاليا
يتم التواصل مع الفنادق
المستعده لايواء مواطنين في مرسين
وانطاليا ونحن نقوم بدعم اللازمه في هذا
الاطار
قدمنا صباحا هذا اليوم الى انطاليا
بتوجيهات من الشجره رئيس الجمهوريه منذ
الصباح
قمنا بثلاثه اجتماعات مع
رواد السياحه والمستثمرين في مجال السياحه
والعاملين في قطاع السياحه قمنا بثلاثه
اجتماعات مختلفه في ثلاثه مناطق مختلفه
اخرها كان في الانيا
مشاهدينا سنكتفي بهذا القدر كانت هذه كلمه
لوزير الخارجيه التركي الذي اكد فيها بان
هناك زياده في عدد فرق الانقاذ التي
ستتوجه للمناطق المنكوبه على كل هذه
الساعه انتهت ولكن التغطيه دائما مستمره
على قناه العربيه بعد قليل مع زميلتي ليال
الاختيار ابقوا معنا